this meeting will come to order
my name is Jim Grayson assembly
member for assembly district
fourteen. And I chair the select
committee. And I want to first.
Thank everyone for being here
good morning to you and welcome
to the very first hearing of the
assembly select committee on
streamlining services for
victims of interpersonal
violence. The purpose of the
select committee is to examine
the colonel's.
The victims of interpersonal
violence face when seeking help
from service providers and law
enforcement.
By reviewing how victims of
interpersonal violence are being
served. I believe that the
legislature can gain important
insight into the ways in which
the state's current laws are
being implemented. And ascertain
whether changes are necessary to
ensure that victims are
receiving the best possible
service and support. The focus
of today's hearing is human
trafficking and the crisis that
California is facing. As you all
know human trafficking is
reported to be the world's
fastest growing criminal
enterprise. And in two thousand
sixteen. At least it was labeled
that two thousand sixteen and
California was actually listed
as the state with the highest
number of reported human
trafficking victims. In order to
help the legislature remain
vigilant in the effort to combat
human trafficking in California.
The select committee hearing
will examine the nature of art
of our state's human trafficking
crisis and assess the services
available human trafficking
victims.
Our goal is to shine a spotlight
on the persistent and growing
problem of human trafficking in
California. And hear from those
who work to serve victims of
human trafficking by by
prosecuting perpetrators and or
by providing services to the
victims. I believe that it's
important to understand that
where we are to that where we
are today and what exist as far
as issues than the current
system in order to improve. And
to move the needle forward to
eliminate human trafficking in
our state.
Today I look forward.
With our special guest and
speakers to hearing testimony
and being further educated on
the issue of human trafficking.
And working with you all as well
by the way thank you to each and
everyone of you for being here.
Are working with you all as well
on this very important topic and
the work that you do that's very
important on a daily basis to
fight this crime. And also work
to protect human trafficking
victims.
So today.
We have.
I do have colleagues and
actually sit on this committee
with me they are working very
hard in their districts.
I would like to list my
colleagues that are part of this
committee its assembly member
Katherine Baker. Assembly member
Jim Cooper assemblymember Jordan
Cunningham assemblymember Eloise
radius and assembly member Marie
Waldron. And.
I don't know if we have any
other elected officials in the
room.
Outside of our VA who will be
introduced here in a minute.
For Alameda county.
With that we are going to move
into our panels now today's
meeting is slated for.
For no more than two hours.
That doesn't mean we have to use
the whole two hours.
It's like.
When I give my my my kid a
twenty dollar bill to go out.
They think they have to use the
whole twenty dollar bill. So
I've learned whether I get my
five or ten or twenty it's all
going to get used. So.
We do have to our slated for it
and.
Speakers thank you.
What you have to say is very
very important as we want to
hear it all?
But we do have time reserved as
well for public comment at the
very end so I would like to.
Welcome our first panel. Out of
three to the Dyess today the
audible* o'malley Alameda
county district attorney. Amanda
prisoner human trafficking
coordinator for California
department of justice. And then
Erin default rate which is a who
is the deputy district attorney
for cops Costa county out of our
district attorney's office right
here and get a long way to
travel.
What to block so welcome? To
the panel and.
The panel will give us an
overview of California's human
trafficking crisis. And I will
simply ask for someone that I
highly admire and the steam
especially. For all the work
you've done to protect and
provide services to victims. Who
also may I note?
Serves on the national board
for.
Family justice centers and was
very instrumental in the very
existence of start of the family
just center now meet a county
which we went and toured and
used as. A model to help us
start right here in Contra Costa
so thank you have a right to
introduce an ask.
District attorney or knowledge
to begin.
Today's panel.
Thank you simply member very
much for a couple of things one
for. Being a champion in this
area and I know that.
That some to this issue around
human
trafficking one of my greatest
concern is that.
We have done a lot to educate
people about the term human
trafficking.
But we cannot become complacent
that somehow because we all know
the language that we have solved
the problem. Because we have not
and so its hearings like this
and attention from leaders like
you that are going to help us to
eventually get to a place where
we can say. We have ended human
trafficking in California.
And I have hope and I have faith
that we will all be able to do
that.
I'm gonna give an overview of
some of the data that we have.
And and a little bit of a
background. Of a few years back
well first of all my first human
trafficking prosecution case was
in nineteen ninety six. And it
involved a twelve year old girl
who's being trafficked by a
thirty nine year old man. Who is
selling her multiple times a
night?
And when she was finally
separated or rescued away from.
The from the purchaser the man
that bought her he was a fifty
year old man. And the police
found her in a motel room with
them they were both prosecuted
by me. For rape. Of her and both
were sent to prison for many
years.
And that was really the
beginning of my education and my
advocacy. On first learning as
much as I can about human
trafficking. And this insidious
crime.
That treats people like their
chattel like they're human ATM
machines and then secondly is to
find the solutions to end human
trafficking. And to serve those
that have been victimized by
this crime.
But part of my effort has been
also creation of the heat
institute that he is human
exploitation trafficking. And
the institute. Isn't is a
funded.
Research institute focusing
solely on California at this
point.
We've been hearings all over
the state of California so we've
gathered a lot of data about how
our communities across
California. Are responding to
and managing their work to
combat human trafficking so some
of the information I will share
with you comes from those those
hearings that we did.
But.
In.
Players and get it players
project is one of the major
players in the country.
And that since two thousand and
seven players project which
managed as it manages the
national hotline. There been
over almost twenty two thousand
calls from California alone
reporting of incidents of human
trafficking. Of those US.
As sixty one hundred almost
sixty two hundred actually
resulted in cases in California.
And all its spot sixty three
hundred victims have been
identified to Clarice now
players is very quick to tell us
that their hotline. So what they
do is if somebody calls in a
report that they direct it right
back to the community I know
that the the justice center here
in Contra Costa. Is very
involved in a zero tolerance in
the various counties so they
have. Identified those areas
where those calls can be
returned.
But into from two thousand and
sixteen to seventeen there were
over four thousand calls from
California alone to the national
hotline.
Thirteen hundred thirty one
cases were reported in
California. And there were.
.
About a third of nine thousand
or three thousand.
Cases that moved forward or that
were investigated were here in
California two hundred and
Oakland alone. And that's my
community.
Some statistics about buyers and
I'm going to give a little bit
of emphasis and when we talk
about where we should be giving
focus. It's on Byers because
right now a person.
Well we've changed a lot over
the last couple of years to
separate fires.
From buyers of adult sex workers
from buyers of children for sex.
And I think this is an important
piece of legislation that was
passed because it allows us to
really. Gather the data that we
need to focus on who's
purchasing children as in those
that are on the spectrum for
child assault for sex offenders.
Are posed just engaging in adult
sex worker which is a different
dynamic.
But we have given no attention
and we have not increased the
punishment of buyers of
children.
That's an effort I will once
again introduce legislative a
sponsor legislation so be our
fourth year. Of trying to change
the punishment for buyers who
are fine children.
In any event fourteen percent of
the men in the United States
report paying for sex fourteen
percent that's fifteen million
men. Who reported and admitted
that they have bought?
I paid for sex seventy five
percent of the church children
who are sexually exploited. Say
they have been inadvertently
sold. Online or they have been
at advertised and sold online.
And according to the New York
University study thirty six of a
percent of all internet content
now is*.
One in four internet searches
for* and at any given time
one point seven million. Users
are streaming*.
Our research shows that there's
a direct link between*. And
on the spectrum of human
trafficking is a purchaser or as
an exploiter.
So we can't miss ought we can't
ignore the impact of* on
this issue.
Locally I in my county one of
our youth guidance centers are
counting centers served a
hundred twenty three you.
Two thousand sixteen Missy and
you'll hear from Dr Haitian maze
later admits he served two
hundred thirty four youth that
are Oakland base you.
Who are all victims of child
sexual exploitation? And the
Oakland police department at
four hundred and five open
cases.
My office is prosecuted over
five hundred and fifty. Human
traffickers. Involving children.
And we have an eighty two
percent conviction rate so when
I my message to my colleagues
across the state is if you think
people will not convict. Human
trafficking because the victim
oftentimes has Vona has
vulnerabilities are the cases
that vulnerabilities look at
Alameda county eighty two
percent conviction. Of those and
that's been is cut a constant
for the last several years.
Fires in the bay area had
incomes sixty one percent at
incomes over sixty thousand
dollars.
The tech industry we have now
discovered has a higher incident
of purchasing so we just need to
give. Some real attention to
that.
We have a safety net program
which we've had since January of
two thousand and eleven.
A working group confidential. A
protected by confidentiality
working group meets every week
and we have met every week since
January first of two thousand
eleven.
And we have now almost eight
hundred used in the database.
And we use the database in order
to educate us about. Common
denominators a bike dynamics
about areas where we should get
focused.
We've seen only about one
percent male but we know that
males are being exploited at a
high rate.
We also are seeing. More youth
that are. That are.
.
Trans gender.
There's no question that for
children particularly that the
incidence of child sexual
exploitation.
Children of color are
disproportionately represented.
And in my county in the stats we
have and I would just say that
are the the people that we work
with the young people. Are that
we have information.
That only about sixty three or
percent are from Alameda county.
We have children that are
identified from other states and
certainly from other counties in
the bay area and for that
reason.
One of the efforts is to have
regional responses as well.
And we're out this particular
bay area is very good at working
between Santa Clara county
contrast to San Francisco
Alameda Solano now down into San
Joaquin to really. Grow that
regional response.
But in my county sixty three
percent of the children that
primarily girls. Are African
American about fifty percent
Latina. And thirty five percent
said that they had.
.
Sorry seventy five percent had
identified their own prior
victimization.
Hi incident of children who have
run away.
So some of the areas that we've
identified that are of great
need and we've given great
attention to.
Are.
Housing. Of course housings an
issue for everybody.
But in this particular
situation there is a lack of
really of lack of housing for
safe housing for children. Or
for young adults who have been
separated away from the
exploiter who are. Who are
getting out of the life for I've
gotten out of the life?
We are encouraging our
communities to think out of the
box the rules around foster care
have changed regarding child
sexual assault excuse me the.
Sexually exploited minors it's a
different licensing structure
now. And so some of the
traditional foster homes are not
able or aren't going to be
moving into that higher level.
We are in Alameda county and
another way we're thinking out
of the box is we can't just rely
on government. Funding although
it's government funding is
there.
That we have partners who want
to step up our faith community
want to step up. Our of
philanthropic community wants to
step up. So one of the efforts
that we're doing right now which
is both Alameda and Contra Costa
is that I reached out to
Catholic charities to the
bishop.
A bishop Michael barber who is
working with us and we are
transforming an old rectory into
a safe house. Long term housing
therapeutic housing for minor
girls.
Or those that identifies female
that will open this spring it's
called Claire's house. And at
the projection is five houses
over the next five years in
Alameda and Contra Costa county
that our partnership with our
faith community. Who and our
faith and the people in our
community as volunteers? Through
the efforts of Claire's house we
have talked to all the parishes
in Alameda Contra Costa we have
over a thousand people have
signed up to be volunteers. To
help work and support and help
the healing of these children so
that when they can get beyond.
Their exploitive experience they
can have the same opportunities
and future that we hope for all
our children.
Housing is a big issue. Out the
role of law enforcement change
the last couple of years and
it's been evolving but we change
but that our legislature changed
it. For sure sing case there's
any questions and that is
children are victims of human
trafficking they're not
perpetrators of crime. So we are
we have re frame the way the law
enforcement is working with
exploited miners. In large part
of being their protectors.
Rather than.
You know bringing kids into
juvenile justice system. And I
will say that again we've been
involving to this point for a
long time so the law which is
the final part the broadest to
there. But we just created a new
protocol on using law
enforcement advisers from all
over the state for law
enforcement so they can re frame
how they're going to interact in
the community. There is a lot of
frustration about where can I
take this child is on the street
or I rescue out the internet one
of my supposed to do next.
And we're trying to answer those
questions and help law
enforcement and all communities
figure out what that looks like.
And then another area we
discovered is that we know that
a lot of children a lot of
adults who are trafficked either
labor or sex traffic. Are going
to the hospitals and going to
clinics for care for medical
treatment so we're working with
all of our hospitals in Alameda
county. Developing a medical
protocols doctor Mays is a
member of the heel network.
Yeah and they're an adviser to
us so we are now working with
each of those hospitals and
physicians and we're looking at
potentially proposing
legislation. Or working with
medical schools to make it a
mandatory part of their medical
training. To learn and
understand human trafficking.
And and then lastly.
You know we many years back.
When I when we got more
organized and that was in the
nineties. That we created what
we what I call he'd watch human
exploitation trafficking and the
watch is where we engage
community. And this is a five
point strategy for communities
to use as a guide. What we do in
Alameda Contra Costa county may
not be the same in Fresno or?
Merced county but this is a
guide that will it help all
communities. And the five
strategies are what working with
law enforcement to help train
law enforcement because very
often they are the first
responders they're the first to
have encountered to encounter
someone. Is being trafficked the
second was we have to prosecute
traffickers. With the many
traffickers will continue
exploiting and continue finding
children to exploit and adults
to exploit so they we just have
to hold them accountable. The
third one is. To make sure that
we have strong community support
and by that I mean and you're
gonna hear from the panel later
so I won't go into it. But
organizations that are in place
to help.
Those.
As they are separated away or
moving into their recovery.
That.
Those nonprofit non government
organizations need to be
supported and strong.
We've been changing the law
since the early since the late
nineties thank goodness to
members like assembly member
Grayson who hears the cry and
understands the need to change
the laws. And then lastly that
it we have to engage our
community this is human
trafficking awareness month.
We've we have to engage our
community because. This is a
crime that is hidden in plain
sight. And the more we.
Have our community be the eyes
and ears and recognize human
trafficking and then a resource
for what they can do once they
see that. The more we are going
to. Change the whole paradigm of
this community of this society.
That would allow this to exist
the last thing I say is we did
Pat the legislature did pass a
law. A few years ago it was SB
eleven ninety three which
requires. Thirteen different
types of businesses to post a
poster. That has some
information about human
trafficking but importantly the
national hotline and we've added
the text line.
I can tell you that we've done
days of action with the with the
family justice center. In a
country Costa we do I'm all the
time in Alameda county there are
wonderful volunteers to do that.
We created an app
to really engage communities so
when I go to a restaurant if I
don't see the sign I can go on
the app. Call at that restaurant
push a red button that says
they're out of compliance with
California law this isn't just a
feel good I wish everybody would
do it. This is the law.
And so we push the button the
district attorney's office the
attorney general's office have
the authority to do
administrative. Enforcement the
fine for failing to put them
poster up in a conspicuous place
is five hundred dollars for the
first offense and a thousand
dollars for every offense after.
And it is my feeling that and
this is what we're doing in my
county that as we find
businesses that don't comply
with the law comply with the
law.
That some of it can fund the
compliance officers but that can
go right back into a pot. For
services for those that have
been exploited.
The businesses that are not
following the law can help us
build the networks and the
resources to help people get
beyond this experience so. If I
know country Costa we've been
uploading all the businesses
into the database so they can
continue to. Days of action
through the leadership of the
justice centers.
And any other community in
California is welcome to it we
have the apt we will share it
with anyone.
And let's get those days of
action going throughout all of
our cities and all of our
counties in California. Thank
you.
Thank you so much district
attorney o'malley and what a
great presentation will move out
right and to amend up listeners
human trafficking coordinator
for the. DOJ.
Thank you to terminate said in
the members of the subcommittee
from biting the department of
justice here today. I'm I'm
pleased to be representing
Attorney General.
Sarah in the department of
justice after the hearing and
the department office of long
prioritize the fighting
instrument half king and
continues to do so today. As
you've heard I'm from both
German Grayson and from MTA
o'malley that statistics.
Nationwide worldwide but
particularly in California
really staggering grew up with
no choice but to lead the fight
against human trafficking.
At.
At the department of justice we
use what's called the four peas
approach to combating
trafficking. At the Ford he's.
Is that a good approach outlined
in the national United Nations
trafficking in persons protocol.
And it includes prevent.
Prosecute. Attacked in partner.
And our goal is to focus her
work on each of those areas.
Most recently on the prevention
front the department of justice.
Supported it work to pass
assembly bill twelve twenty
seven I've that bill. Outlaw
mandates human trafficking it
education in public schools
throughout the state.
I'm.
That education helps students to
protect themselves and protect
each other and make sure that
every young person understands
that commercial faxes not a
victimless crime.
The curriculum called protectors
originally rolled out a role
communities than there is an
expansion and will now be
available to students statewide.
And data is also being collected
to evaluate the effectiveness of
this educational curriculum.
Data collected from seventh and
ninth graders show that ninety
five percent of the students who
have been educated. With this
curriculum felt that they could
identify trafficker tactics
after receiving that training.
In addition our office continues
to enforce.
And implement.
Statewide anti trafficking
initiatives like I feel I've
been ninety three which damn
alley mention which is. I
recently been amended. By SP at
two twenty five which require
the department of justice to
create. And it enumerated
entities to post a human
trafficking I'm.
No death that in. Includes
multiple types of reporting it
information that phone number
and dad and awaited fended
information by text message.
We're working with the state
agencies responsible for
oversight of some of those
covered entities tie identify
implementation gaps. In any need
for enforcement actions.
By the department of justice
for other other locally add
prosecutorial entity if.
The department office also works
tirelessly everyday at stake
traffickers off the street by
investigating and prosecuting
offenders.
The department of justice houses
a multi agency task force in San
Diego. The task force comprised
of local state and federal law
enforcement.
Service providers
and prosecutors.
And that it has for tape task
force takes a collaborative a
regional approach human
trafficking which is the met
with much success.
Last year the task force
arrested at ninety three
traffickers.
Eighty nine of those traffickers
faced state charges for face to
federal charges.
In addition to those charges.
Are the task force if this
provided assistance and support
to fifty eight back down.
And conducted twenty one
trainings in the San Diego area
for students government
employees law enforcement
officers in the public.
Those trainings are geared
towards raising awareness and
making sure that everyone in the
community in their workplace are
in their day to day lives is
able to identify trafficking
when they see it. And knows what
to do out when they've
identified at.
In addition it.
This past year the department of
justice is filed a number of top
ad cases against human
traffickers.
One such case was filed. In the.
The middle of the year was
against.
Three defendants who were
charged with.
Fraudulently procuring a luxury
residential units
and cars which they then
proceeded to use to traffic
thirteen victims up and down the
state. Including eight miners.
Just a couple of weeks ago two
of the three defendants pled
guilty. Wanted twenty eight
years and one to eleven years
I'm an outcome we are very
pleased with.
In the course of this work we
also take I very careful steps
to protect.
The survivors who we encounter.
We work closely with service
providers very early on from
that very.
Start of our investigations to
make sure that.
Victims and survivors needs are
met.
At each step of the way both
mental health needs it though
think that physically than any
other needs add that. The
individuals may have.
The exact nature of the support
and services that are provided.
If of course determined in a
substantial part by the needs of
that particular individual.
But they can include a.
Housing mental health the drug
and alcohol counseling.
Emergency housing in basic
needs like medical care food and
clothing.
Service providers we work with
are also available to shepherd
survivors through the court
process.
And at that survivors election
it to stay on that support them
even after the close of the
case.
Additionally attorneys in office
take.
Take steps to ease the burden of
it.
That survivors have facing a
trafficker in court.
I am for survivor that is a very
very challenging oftentimes most
times. To go to court. To look
their trafficker in their faith
in the face and a half to
describe sexual encounters. And.
Other awful things that.
That took place while they were
being trafficked.
We try to assist in the.
To assist them in that endeavor
and to make it. Too easy the
burden to the fact that we can
we do a few things.
The first is we will.
Take survivors who are who are
at anticipated to testify to
court in advance of whatever
hearing or have to buying in to
do a courtroom that that.
I that enables the survivor to
get a lay of the land to see the
court room to go up on the
witness stand that actually
experience what that will feel
like.
And even though it's. Generally
empty courtroom at that time but
to have that first step.
In feeling quite that testimony
will feel like you were able to
upgrade to answer any questions.
And.
To do anything we can to to warm
up the environment for that.
Individual up.
We also work.
Arrange for. Anything survivor
who is testifying who would like
to have a support person
available to actually have that
person up on the witness stand
with them to.
To provide additional support at
the time of testimony in front
of. Add the trafficker in the
public a Jerry.
And lastly we.
Would go out of our way to make
sure that the audience is filled
with familiar faces and. Add
that there is additional
security in the courtroom so
that I need.
Survivor who we have to testify
knows that they are safe and
supported.
As this collaborative approach
with service providers have you
but many successes.
I purchased a few examples.
I last year on. That. One case
we worked at the service
provider to get. Eighteen age a
trafficking victim back into
school so that she could
receive.
Her GED and she is now taking
classes at a local community
college.
Have.
And more recently we at the
citadel picked on.
Who?
With an ad desperate need of
substance abuse treatment and
after. Getting.
Part way through that treatment.
That.
That survivor was able to share
with us that this was the first
time in ten years that she had
left.
The life and was not under the
control of a trafficker Pam.
And that she had.
As a result the calm the a
better mother to her children.
Finally we partner with
government agencies advocacy
groups and service providers to
train a broad range of people up
and down the state.
I in the identification
reporting with you in
trafficking it's often these
folks did not law enforcement.
Who are best positioned to
observe trafficking in their
community either in their
workplace as? For example we've
trained government employees
who.
Perform building in code
enforcement work.
In the identification of
traffickers in those locations
I've trafficking victims in
those locations.
We've trained healthcare
hospitality workers are
identification of trafficking
victims in the hospitals and
hotels.
And we've trained teachers who
are. Around here the whispers in
the hallway into notice a change
in a child's demeanor behavior.
Despite our best efforts there
are of course still gaps in our
sport I've trafficking
survivors.
I would reiterate that point
that the a rally made about how
things specifically for I.
juvenile trafficking survivors.
Do the Taliban that forms
between it I trafficking
survivors. And their
traffickers.
Juvenile survivors signatory
flee right away from whatever
placement it is that they're put
in.
I despite law enforcement's best
efforts to keep them safe.
Fortunately there is a
significant shortage of safe
victim oriented placements for
juveniles who been trafficked.
Juvenile hall they're not the
proper place for the survivors
that they're victims of crime
not criminals.
But urban foster. Group foster
homes or group homes are also
not.
The right place.
Those locations lack the the
structure and the. Staff who are
trained in commercially sexually
exploited children.
And.
Better really necessary for the.
For the juvenile. Ad trafficking
survivors it to.
To thrive.
And it to heal from the
trafficking situation that they
were at.
At.
Example that we've experienced
my office related to that wise.
In a recent case where juvenile
trafficking Sir at.
You're the victim. Than survivor
ritualized located in central
California the trafficker was in
southern California.
That young woman traveled
several hundred miles on her
own.
Three times.
To be to re unite with her
trafficker despite having being
rescued were covered by law
enforcement. And each of the
previous times.
It wasn't until she was placed
in this case that her parents
expense.
A camp in a rural town out of
state.
That she was able to break free
of the traffickers mental
control over her. You really
begin to heal.
And.
It begins to get back to the
place that she was before she
was initially contacted by the
proper.
And despite the research gaps
that remain in the hard work
that that is certainly a lot to
do with the fight against human
trafficking is under way. And we
can't allow and won't allow
traffickers to continue to.
Target
very vulnerable that segments of
our population.
Nor what will we are kind we
allowed the. Strong survivors of
this crime to be left behind.
The Attorney General is the
chief law enforcement officer of
the state.
Is committed to continuing the
strong work I've his
predecessor.
And remaining a leader in the
fight.
And we look forward to continue
discussions.
In partnership with legislature
to stop human trafficking and
provide victims of the critical
services they need to be
survivors.
And it to thrive.
And thank you again to chair and
the members of the subcommittee
for having the department of
justice here today and I look
forward to answering any
questions.
This was not thank you for your
presentation and we will before
questions come. Which we do have
some.
Before they come we will turn
to our final panelist to speak
and present.
Mister Aaron to fari for a
deputy district attorney for
cost cost accounting thank you
for being here.
First they determine very.
When the.
Thank you chairman Grayson for
putting this committee together.
I really do want to emphasize
what this return your mallee
already said which is but we
appreciate your ongoing efforts
here we want to make sure that
human trafficking is not. Just a
flavor of the month or flavor of
the year type of crime where
everybody learns about it and
then like district attorney
o'malley said we become
complacent. Because we've
already heard about it so thank
you for continuing this fight we
really do appreciate it.
The next person I would think is
district attorney o'malley. It's
I think it goes without saying
but I'm gonna say it anyways she
has been the tip of the spear.
And her offices been the
flagship in fighting human
trafficking in California we
have modeled a number of efforts
that we've undertaken is
chairman grace and set. Off of
what she has done and we.
.
I feel a little bit out of place
sitting next to her on a panel
like this but I'll do my best.
What I want to talk about today?
And what I think is relevant for
the conversation you're starting
here. Is there's two two issues
I want to talk about and one is
the need for multi
jurisdictional efforts in our
county.
To attack and prosecute human
trafficking operations
particularly large scale. Human
trafficking operations and the
next topic I wanted to address
after I talk about that is
what's already been touched on
by deal Nelly. And a
representative from DOJ and that
is addressing how to meet
victims where they are and more
properly how to ensure that they
become survivors of human
trafficking. And just the
partnerships that we are
required to forge and make that
happen and it's it's not easy
especially the county as diverse
as ours with as many different
jurisdictions as we have. Our
county is a little different we
have all types of different
populations here and so it's not
always easy to coordinate those
efforts. But I'm proud to say
that I think we've made great
progress there.
So first in terms of multi
jurisdictional investigations
what we've discovered but what
we have not yet perfected and
we're working hard to
accomplish.
Is developing a task force
approach to trafficking.
Investigations specifically we
have a really frankly FBI safe
streets task force here in
Contra Costa county they partner
with us and our agencies and
specifically the DA's office. To
attack large scale criminal
enterprise and problematic.
Particularly criminal street
gang violence issues and as part
of that we have accomplished
several large scale human
trafficking investigations
through for example wire taps. A
one of the. Investigations we
managed to accomplish that was
particularly surprising was a
human trafficking operation that
had been running out of Danville
for approximately fifteen years
and also parts of Alameda county
Livermore.
In Dublin.
And it was one individual named
James Joseph junior who had been
running women adult women across
the country. For fifteen years
starting at approximately two
thousand or two thousand one
Mister Joseph had trafficked
victims all across the country.
And his method was he would lie.
To the women you would me he
pick on eighteen nineteen twenty
year old women he tell them they
were beautiful. And that they
would be models or maybe make up
artists and we travel across the
country and make hundreds of
thousands of dollars. Mister
Joseph was a very good con man.
He dressed the part he had their
expensive cars he had rented a
number of very nice houses from
San Ramon to Danville which is.
One of our more affluent
communities in Qatar Costa
county. And he would learn these
women in and after two or three
meetings and he would bring his
other girls the other survivors
the other trafficking victims
with him. And they would play
the part of success model.
He would bring them in and after
two or three appointments he
would get the next victim alone.
Raper
tell her he had all of his
information all of her
information rather. And then he
would say you're going to be in
the trafficking ring or I'm
going to kill your family.
A Mister Joseph it pull that off
for fifteen years.
Fifteen years he had been
arrested by the federal
government on more than one
occasion.
Is trafficking activities had
been detected in New York. Ohio
places like that but at the
time.
We didn't recognize as a
society.
Or is the law enforcement
community.
What human trafficking look like
and so when he was arrested for
these crimes it wasn't fully
appreciated the scope of what
he'd been perpetrating so we
just a short stints in federal
prison?
But he kept at it.
Finally in two thousand and
fifteen through some incredibly
alert work by members of the San
Ramon police department. They
listened to one of his survivors
one of Mister Joseph survivors
speak at a human trafficking
awareness conference. He brought
the case to San Ramon police
department. They did a lot of
surveillance work and our human
trafficking.
.
Deputy will we have one human
trafficking jeopardy in Contra
Costa county now and we're
working to increase that.
But they brought it to our
office we got together with the
safe streets task force and
initiated a wiretap
investigation. And what that
wiretap investigation turned
over was just what I said Mister
Joseph it conducted a nationwide
human trafficking ring. For sex
for the better part of fifteen
years. We brought a forensic
accountant in an eBay roughly.
One point five to two million
dollars per year running the
human trafficking ring.
Through the wiretap
investigation and some
phenomenal work thanks in large
part to. Our partners who
sponsor a victim witness
advocacy program at the
California department of justice
and the state. We were able to
develop a number of victims.
Put Mister Joseph and his
partner his common law wife on
trial for human trafficking and
multiple counts of rape. That
investigation came to a
successful close actually less
than three or four months ago
and Mister Joseph.
Was sentenced last week to a
hundred and seventy four years
to life in the state
penitentiary. Which is
absolutely the right result but
it was a lot of work and it was
only made possible by the
cooperation of multiple
jurisdictions and the FBI safe
streets task force.
We need to expand that.
What DA o'malley is done in her
jurisdiction by creating he task
force is a great model to
follow?
It obviously each county each
city is unique and Carter Costa
needs to have its own solution
but one that looks a lot like
what DO now is done. The head of
our sexual so unit right now
senior deputy district attorney
Paul graves is working hard. To
create a human trafficking task
force a one day is not being.
Somewhat multi task if you will
with combating gang violence
because that's incredibly
important and they've made
tremendous strides especially
with the freeway shooting
epidemic we had here. But also
focuses on human trafficking
because that deserves its own
taskforce and that deserves its
own resources. So we're working
to create that.
We need more support we need
more help our law enforcement
agencies have been tremendously
supportive of that and we hope
they'll continue to do that.
The next topic I want to talk
about is streamlining victim
services which which is a large
part of why we're here today.
And.
Again I want to commend.
German Grayson and a number of
the elected officials in our
county who have worked to bring
us to family justice centers. We
have Susan came here today who.
Has done a ton of work in that
area and we we couldn't be
happier with what we've achieved
and again. This is more of a
approach where we've learned a
lot by watching what Alameda
county is done. And we've
created two family justice
centers and the I think the
strength of that is we've
created a type of one stop
shopping if you will. For
victims of family violence.
Victims of sexual assault and
particularly victim of victims
of human trafficking.
Those are great strides forward
but we can still do more.
What we've seen and we started
to dress your day and I think
it's really important is that we
don't have enough beds just just
plain and simple? Our
infrastructure in terms of how
we how is vulnerable victims or
survivors of human trafficking
is completely lacking.
We don't have safe places for
them to go and there's tension
especially for our. Minor
victims of human trafficking
there's a lot of tension between
what was already identified
where do you put a minor victim
of human trafficking because we
know that. Group homes foster
homes those can be places where
they're re victimized or their
re recruited back into
trafficking rings. So we need
places that are completely
focused on human trafficking we
need more bed space is available
and we need to have those
accessible through our family
justice centers. And those
places do have to be task
specific meaning for human
trafficking victims they need to
address some of our most common
ailments are most common.
Syndromes that affect our human
trafficking victims such as post
traumatic stress disorder and
substance abuse because many of
our traffickers. Many of our
traffickers use drugs such as
methamphetamine heroin cocaine a
number of the prescription drugs
that are abused today to get. A
young women addicted so they can
keep them in their employ it's.
Manipulation method are
traffickers use so we absolutely
need to have trafficking spaces
trafficking beds available where
those types of.
Shoes are dressed.
And.
I think one other part of that
and and it's already been
discussed today. But I do think
coupling or. Multiplying or
increasing our efforts with
partner partnering with
nonprofit organizations non
governmental organizations is
something we still need to work
on this county we are. Getting
there but we're not there there
are brilliant organizations a
Catholic Church is definitely
stepped up in a lot of ways but
we have other non religious
affiliated organizations like
pillars of pillars of hope is
religiously affiliated but. Arm
of care which is a great
organization does a lot of work
with human trafficking victims
specifically trafficking victims
we need to. Continue to build
our relationships with those
types of organizations.
I would.
Finally like to mention that.
There is one last field of human
trafficking they were still
building out into and you're
gonna hear later today I believe
from Louise Reeves who works for
Pittsburgh police department she
is a. Resource that we could not
do without I've said before I'll
say it again I wish we had ten
Louise Reeves is but
intelligence analysis for human
trafficking. Is a monster part
of the equation to effectively
attack and prosecute you and
trafficking I would I guess I'd
add this back into my multi
jurisdictional approach we need
to take a social. Networking
intelligence analysis to how we
attack human trafficking and for
example in San Francisco a lot
of the way that they deal with
gang violence and they
investigate gang violence. That
takes place when they look at
network analysis they look at
who contacts to who knows who
and they build out complicated
nexus maps to determine where
violence will occur next it's
pretty sophisticated model.
Louise Reeves at Pittsburgh Pete
is taking an intelligence
analysis approach to determining
where and when human trafficking
is occurring we need to do that
on the next level. And I think
that that doesn't have to be
individualized departments are
in visual police departments I
think would be an excellent
addition to human trafficking
task force.
So thank you gonna some women.
Should the time.
Thank you for your presentation
deputy de eight of ari and.
.
Your presentations for all three
of you were fantastic. I I wrote
down a couple of quotes here.
Because it was said and I I
have just a a question I'm gonna
ask you that we're gonna get on
to the next panel. So I'm sure
we will be able to exhausted
today about something for you to
think about and hopefully a
provide some feedback to my
office. Because I really do want
to provide some assistance to be
a resource to you.
Some statements were made that
that traffickers if not
prosecuted will continue to
traffic. And then the quote we
have to prosecute traffickers
and then.
It was made known by this place
for one of the four pieces
prosecute. And then.
A comment that was made quote
unquote we need more help. The
question that I would have for
you is what barriers currently
exist that would limit or impede
your offices efforts to
prosecute human traffickers. And
part to that question is what
can lead just what can lead to
the legislature do to help law
enforcement combat human
trafficking and assist the
victims.
Well.
Part of the part of the
challenge is that.
That.
Those that have been trafficked
some don't trust the system
because they've been trained and
taught not to. So they don't
necessarily see the police as
their protector.
But that's the first thing the
bonding that.
That miss builder talked about
is real and we need to make sure
that we are providing.
A lot of support to those that
are separated away from the
trafficker.
For them to be able to come into
court and testify.
I your legislature has passed
several of bills which I'm proud
of sponsored about. Having
closed circuit TV testimony and
doing are taking conditional
examination testimony early on
before the case actually. Hits
the the trial stage and I think
those are important tools.
But I do believe that.
That we need to in order to
successfully prosecute we need
to have witnesses.
And so how we're able to
support.
And provide the resources to
those victims and witnesses
early on.
Is really critical to their
ability to stay with us and be
available to come and testify.
Excellent thank you.
One of the most significant.
Barriers continues to be
resources.
Other mentioned we have.
The department does that house
is a tough sport and see an ego
that has been quite successful
however.
At the department is only able
to see currently to staff that
have forced with three agents
including a supervisor.
And.
So in short our court allocating
additional resources to this
collaborative regional.
Mold. Approach to human
trafficking that we've seen it
at be successful both at the
scene a good half fourth I know
in the in Alameda county. Is
well and.
I I think would be something
certainly to address with
additional resources we would be
able to grow the existing task
force. I'm the DOJ houses and
ideally replicate that passport.
And central California northern
California
so that there is a greater reach
an ability to investigate.
More traffickers arrive to
prosecute war traffickers.
I think at second exactly what's
been said so far in in an. Ad
that in our office unfortunately
to date there's typically been
one for the last four years
assigned deputy district
attorney to prosecute human
trafficking. The truth is we
need more it these are very
complex cases they I often say
that they're sort of the
marriage in a bad way between
gang prosecution and domestic
violence prosecution because our
witnesses are unwilling. And
they're very mobile. Are
unfortunately are survivors are
very able to go from one place
to the next so the management of
the case takes a lot of time. I
will say that I am I am
appreciative of the efforts for
example assemblywoman Baker I
know sponsored legislation to
make all human trafficking
prosecutions vertically
prosecuted. Meeting one
prosecutor handled the case from
the filing to the end of the
case from cradle to grave if you
will. So I simply think we need
more resources and that. Goes
hand in hand with the bell being
our human trafficking task
force.
So obviously resources are
limited on every level we're all
feeling the crunch.
I know that.
If I if I am correct.
That to and this is a little
off.
Maybe topic but what will bring
it right back real quick because
we have to get to the next
panel.
But.
In in drug enforcement.
When there is an arrest. And
prosecution there are.
Seizures of assets.
Is that something that also
exist in the trafficking world
where you can.
Seize assets and use that to
actually help the healing side
or of victims.
Yes so am.
In the loop like two thousand.
Eleven twelve thirteen. We will
eat the legislature was able to
enact legislation that added
human trafficking to the
forfeiture statute. The place
where we see resources that are
identifiable is in labor
trafficking. And we've been very
successful at seizing. Buildings
and businesses and then being
able to provide research
restitution to the victims or to
pay for their. For their finding
the victims of crime fund which
is something that people don't
always think about.
That all prosecutor office in
the Attorney General get funds
for. And that is to.
Provide counselling for victims
and it does provide for
relocation if there's no safe
place.
And so that those are resources
that are there.
To help.
Augment.
The.
The forfeiture but in the sex
trafficking it's.
Again it's a fluid for most of
what we see are lower level
traffickers. Are the big cases
like the case in Danville.
That case.
I would expect that under most
circumstances seizing the house
and selling the house is
completely within the realm of.
The law enforcement authority or
the prosecutors authority with
course with the court. I and
that.
Read those resources can become.
Restitution or they can also go
back into.
Of being able to support that
counties.
Efforts to continue the work
excellent thank you very much
and thank you to all the
panelists that we were I really
appreciate your presentation.
They're worthy of a good hand
from us audio so we have.
We will now transition to our
next panel and.
We will be able to hear from
law enforcement and.
Their response to human
trafficking.
And.
While there a while the
transitions taking place I do
wanna think district attorney
o'malley this place near a
deputy district attorney to fari
for.
The excellent testimony
presentation.
And.
As we are inviting the next
panel up to the Dyess.
I will. Introduce them. And we
have with this corporal.
Tony Gilliam.
Now with the Concord police
department. And we also have
Louise Reeves the community
service specialists with
Pittsburgh police department as
well.
Yeah.
We are entering our last half of
the time for the panel so we
look forward to hearing from.
Part two presenters.
And I will simply reach out and.
Have.
Corporate Killian if you want to
go out and kick it off just make
sure you get the little button
on the side.
Green light comes on go for.
I think you for others here Sir.
I'm actually have a Louise
reason start with the most the
conversation she doesn't mostly
heavy lifting.
I recently laughter special
victims unit on back on the
street and want to be motivated
my squad to be focusing on this
on a daily basis.
Well nightly basis of working
nights.
But Louis is gonna go into more
the in depth.
So be it let's do it.
Good morning thank you chairman
grace of having us here today.
I'm.
I'm surprised to be here but
this is just as great I'm so
excited that call to Costa
county is really recognizing the
problems that we have out here.
I am.
What is a community service
specials the pits but please
department I'm not a police
officer?
I have for the last ten years
been investigating my weight
juveniles. And over the lost.
Basically since two thousand
eleven when I had my first
trafficking case. I really
recognize that this is a giant
problem that we have here in
Contra Costa county. My first
case was a girl she was fourteen
years old she was picked up on
railroad Avenue in Pittsburgh.
By two guys who wanted to invite
her to a party. Of four hours
later she's in hot topics in
Alameda meeting a man for a
date.
In the short time that she was
the way she was taken to.
Hotels in Union City Hey would.
At San Jose Monterey and down to
because filled.
It was then that I learned how
multi jurisdictional this
problem is I'm how we all have
to work together.
It was actually the case
actually sent to because I had
no crime in Pittsburgh at that
time it was actually fought by a
union city down in Alameda
county.
Big I have for me.
.
Fourteen years old my daughter
at the time was fourteen. The.
.
The victim ended up being my
told his. Best friend's cousin.
So that's really kind of what
board come to me just how close
this is and how how it affects
us Texas all.
So we were given today some
questions.
.
And I kind of just a bullet
point I didn't know how to kind
of present this so one of the
questions was was has a human
trafficking changed. Yes in the
last ten years I've seen big
changes in this and especially
since two thousand eleven.
And the biggest change for me
as well.
Arent differ are you just spoke
about. Was the social media.
I am seeing off.
Social media just explode with.
.
Pandering.
You know recruitment I monitors
social media and and justice
quick case a few weeks ago I had
my I have multiple screens on my
desk. And I had my Facebook feed
up and Facebook live popped up
this that young man trying to
get to go into a vehicle. I this
kind of.
Struck a red flag with me so I
did a a workup on this this
gentleman he lived in Antioch.
And it during the work up I
found his phone number and that
phone number was a satiated to
prostitution acts.
I said all this information over
to Anya out PT annual PP started
building a case on him in the
meantime I had a runaway
juvenile from Pittsburgh. And.
Richmond PD picked up they sent
me a picture they found on her
cell phone.
From her Instagram account and
then like do you know this guy
and I'm like well yes I do.
trying to get and I got into a
cough so this is why all social
media has to be monitored I'm on
it I literally I'm on it even a
home at eleven o'clock at night.
Just scrolling through Instagram
Facebook life Snapchat I don't
tweet I don't have time for it.
So I'm big.
Big changes that.
Another change I've seen is.
It's been glorified.
You know we have this
glorification that we have
comedy be we have Nicki Minaj we
have JZ all rapping about human
trafficking. And it has been
glorified with sending this
message to all our youth that
this is okay and it's not.
I seen a big big changes and
that.
We talked I am saying.
Pandering for the internet I
just had a case of a girl who
returned home she was a
Pittsburgh run away. As she let
me look up her phone and what I
was going for her phone they
don't think I'm going to be able
to find much on the phone they
don't think I'm really that sad
because I'm a fifty year old
grandma.
But I know my way around the
phone and as I was going for
this phone I found that she was
being pandered by her friend a
seventeen year old friend was
telling her to contact an
exploiter. In Sacramento to make
money.
.
That's just not acceptable when
did it become OK to friends to
refer friends to exploit as.
One the other things I'm seeing
is tattooing and branding. I've
got girls as young as thirteen
but tattoos of the exploit its
name on them. And this is kind
of late on the list I want to
talk about maybe we mandating
them as mandated
reporters if they suspect human
trafficking and possibly going
after these.
Tattoo artists for tattooing a
thirteen year old it's illegal.
So I'd like to see sort of more
that.
I am seeing more about victims
being trafficked in more
affluent areas.
Before the fires and I had
quite a few up in the Santa Rosa
area assignment file seen them
going down to Santa Clara I'm
not saying it's not still
happening over in Oakland I know
it is. But I am seeing that's
where the money is.
Diego Maddie talked about of the
tech industry you know that that
heading down to that area.
What are we doing?
?
Social media monitoring I'm like
I said I'm on it all the time.
I monitor a prostitution ads I
go through the pages I go
through the back pages I go for
the night shift at night shift
has a lot of information. Out
there are few matlab and to
manage your way through that.
We investigate or suspicions of
HT you don't become threatened
by.
Mandated reporters through the.
Sub social workers will for the
schools we investigate
everything nothing is now
suspicious circumstance we look
at the. That were investigated.
Working with other agencies is
huge high what Creek Tony and
I'm going to go into it just a
little case. Auto unite what
many cases together. But we
recently had a case last year of
a fourteen year old girl who is.
Running wait Pittsburg shoes
one of Tony's Kelson. Twenty put
in contact how mommy contact
with me.
And we worked this case together
aye why it turns out this
thirteen fourteen year old.
Although she won't admit the
trafficking it led to another
victim which led to another
victim I think at this point
where now it fourteen victims.
From around wait
I'm hoping they get this guy
very soon.
Room.
Meeting with nonprofits not NGOs
faith based groups I'm I'm very
involved in that as a lot of the
other agents who thought they
are huge to us there are huge
resource.
So we really recognize the value
of all these groups.
Human trafficking operations.
We we try and do them. As always
a manpower issue.
You know we'd like to see more.
Funding and resources to help us
with that but we do need to do
these John and.
Exploiter operations and I am
especially passionate about the.
The purchases
and we really should be going
off to them I it's a
preventative measure. And like
the idea of ID said we need to
be. You know that they need
these to ninety registrations
home these purchases.
You we need to be getting.
More prosecutions on them I
have a phone in my possession
from adult who was thirteen at
the time. I had a search warrant
written on it.
.
I got over thirty men China by
this goal on that phone. I have
she looks like she's nine years
old and have prostitution ads we
don't have the time or the
resources to go off to every
number to go off to every person
that was trying to buy these
female.
.
We are out in the schools and
then the community I just last
week trying to one of the high
schools.
We need to be doing more might
target area for business it's my
opinion it's not depend on the
police department we meet need
for teaching awful for fifth
graders.
We need to be out that educating
them at that age.
By high school it's too late by
middle school it's almost too
late my youngest victim for me
has been the eleven.
I we need to be talking about
recognizing the signs that said
early on and and that parents
the parents need to be involved
in this education.
I have department training hard
to office is a trained on human
trafficking recognize the signs
of human trafficking.
I believe they should have more
but again it's that time in a
funding issue.
I have we participated and.
S. B. eleven ninety three and I
actually have to say it was a
lot of fun. I was surprised how
well we received got we well we
will receive from the when out
to these businesses.
It was section a fun afternoon
I really enjoyed doing that and
I know they'll be enough one
coming up.
We work very closely with neck
mac and national Senate missing
exploited children huge resource
are often norm Forstmann.
I'm one of things I like about
the national citizens when
children this they will do
analysis for you. They wrote
analysis on social media council
on.
You know possible exploit is
and they they will help with
that they also get the flies out
for you and they keep track of
data. So they are keeping a
track of. The amount of.
Since you know and that's why we
really need to all be referring
op.
Children to neck neck so they
can keep better statistics.
That we have a wonderful
program I'm not going to get its
name away but law enforcement
has a. Huge program.
Ashton Krishna is the founder
of this program and the big fan
of his off that this. And if I
didn't have this program I
couldn't do the work that I'm
doing it is huge.
We need to getting this not
wonderful some agencies have it
and it's free. And every time I
get because I have multiple
agencies calling me all the time
because I've what's kind got
around that I.
I know what I'm doing.
I might wear your using this
program that I know we don't
know about it and I can it's
free just apply for it's a huge
asset so I'm trying to get the
word out about everyone using.
This program.
We work well with probation and
parole.
Probation is huge in fact.
.
Just recently I really have to
equip probation the district
attorney's office I had a
runaway juvenile aye before she
left she stole. A consumer and
money from her family member.
And what I wrote of petty theft
case on have because I hate to
say this.
It was a way I knew I could get
for safe.
And the aye actualizado two it
probation weak and per.
The district has office we got
the case file it and the judge.
Thank
you judge issued and extradite
will warrant.
We found her in Phoenix aye
founder in Phoenix for social
media if we didn't have that
warrant we probably would not go
ahead back to get have safe.
.
One of the things when our full
spent sorry I would note we
really have to develop good
relationships of the families of
these.
Not a white cities trafficking
victims because they are help
these girls often reach out to
them.
And they give us information and
it's a it's really important to.
Have a good relationship with
these these families.
A for the questions office
varias I think.
The biggest barrier is keeping
the juvenile safe that's the.
Biggest problem that we have in
my ideal world we'd be building
a home on the top of a mountain
surrounded by bats coyotes the
snakes.
So these girls would not run
because they also into the life
that they do run that we need
the support in the counseling in
the help for them.
.
We as we talked about we are
century victimizing our children
right now because we cannot
detain them.
Of various is then not willing
to talk they've they often don't
see themselves as the victim.
And that's a huge problem for us
I'd like to go in when I find a
victim I to talk to on a Friday
because I don't write uniform on
Friday I got my civilian clothes
to welcome Friday. And that
because I'm not in a police
uniform. I'm a mom I my grandma
they do tend to open up a little
bit. But not very often you know
but it does help that time not
seen as a person of law
enforcement.
We have the reluctance the often
very reluctant to get out of the
life.
They.
They see that exploiters that
provider.
And that's very hard that trauma
bond that was spoken about
earlier is very very hard to
break.
The resources needed was one of
the questions funding we need
funding we need more people we
need more help.
This is this is a giant battle
that we're facing right now.
.
A kid housing for juveniles I
just spoke about that
specialized housing for adult
victims that's open twenty four
seven that's nothing was
someone.
Tony and I have we had if I had
this a few weeks ago we find a
victim.
I am the thin air space like a
put who was in fact filled.
You no we need some think that
we can we can keep them you know
low because they.
But away from their exploiters.
So what can the legislative do
then this is just.
Mike my feelings.
Pacha cuts the time for
suspects said Diamanti talked
about that many big proponent of
that let's put these guys away
for a very very long time.
Funding for personnel to work
these cases education I spoke
about that harsher sentences for
the buyers I spoke about that.
I really to see some kind of.
.
Penalize ation for hotels.
I just had a fourteen year old I
just spoke to and she was
telling me that. The exploit a
was given the hotel five hundred
dollars.
To keep quiet.
So I really think that you know
we meet we nay to start going
off the hotels and and and into
prosecuting them for tying the
blind diet such.
Mandate tattoo parlors and now
follow up and nail salon spear.
Mandated reporters I I think you
know the schools alumni had done
they one that now it's done.
But I think that's a great place
to start especially the talk to.
Pause.
A jurisdiction.
Right now if.
But I'd I'm not a legal person
I don't quite know how this
works but I've just had a case
of a.
Spec all. And nothing happened
in Contra Costa county and it
was all in Alameda county so
that is actually going down I
spoke to he would PD in that's
going down be filed next week
and Hey what it.
But why copy five hit.
You know I mean I victims here I
I'd like to see you know if it's
my case.
I should own it.
Rob wouldn't give it to someone
else.
Then that's just my personal
opinion but I'd like to see
maybe you know at some changes
that.
And another thing.
.
Is hippa I mean we kind of
spoken out earlier I had a big
debate with adulta.
About he was telling me how he
knew who these skills quirk who
the trafficking victims web
because. Basically he was an
OBGYN and they were coming in
and he was cleaning them up. And
three months later they were
back again I might but your
mandate a report he says but
that protected by hip.
So I again I'm not legal I don't
know how that works but it he
signalman recognizing them.
Out opposite doing that then
maybe we need to make some
changes right that.
And I think that's about all I
have to say.
But just and is there anything
else the safety corporate
really.
Actually no that's actually Y.
one Louise to go first.
Always very thorough.
I'm one things I want to talk
about it's been said before but.
I want to reiterate it we need a
multi angle approach we have
take out every lake of this
chair if we want to bring it
down.
We have to target the buyers.
Stricter penalties
because for people who are
buying these children.
Against the pimps we'd have
aggressive investigation by the
police officers.
The more training we have the
better the more we know how to
do our jobs better.
And then cooperation with our de
is.
To insure the prosecution.
And also and.
Certainly important I can't.
Stressed enough to provide
services
services and to be available
twenty four hours.
I work nights.
I don't work.
I I will not be able to call
services at noon and say Hey I
need help with me and I'm
calling it to three four o'clock
in the morning.
Can I have one shot to get that
woman that victim off the street
and get her health.
I've talked survivors in the
average time they've told me is
they've been offer services
sixteen times before they get
out of a life.
I have to if I have one shot I
have to make it count.
It have to be able to reach him
twenty four seven.
Big server what next week.
Absolutely in thank you for your
very thorough and.
.
And corporal.
Killian your expeditious.
Presentation.
Recall the questions were
answered and.
I just
a going back to one thing I know
if the move quickly we have
another panel to to hear from.
But going back to.
The resources.
And.
We went that.
Is there any kind of a way that
there can be a a closer bond or.
Communication with these non
governmental agencies or groups
that could possibly provide
services whether it's Catholic
charities or others. Are are
local agencies.
Such as police departments
meeting with potential.
Groups that could become
resourceful to you or has a
something that's yet to.
Come to fruition in
celebrated by police
departments.
We belong to at the alliance to
offend and abuse coalition and
we meet quarterly and prove that
we have got lots of information
on the family justice center.
Lots of information on you know
who can help us
and I'm I'm very lucky Pittsburg
PD that we do have a victim
witness Africa who works out of
our office. And I am really good
friends with the. Neighborhood
who is.
Who does the victim witness
over the more my speed dial soap
we do have an issue I am able to
call them because at this point
I'm kind of rushing around
trying to get the H. T.
investigation Dodd? And I can
meet with that and then they
stop calling all all the groups
see what help we can get
fantastic in this is a perfect
segue and to our next panel. Our
next panel are.
Service providers that we're
going to be able to hear from so
I would like to make that train.
Transition as we enter into the
latter part of our.
Special.
Session today.
And we will invite our service
providers.
To come to the Dyess.
And as they are.
I do want a fake.
Corporal Killian as well as
miss Reeves for your
presentation.
Very thorough and it's good to
hear from law enforcement.
And now we're excited to hear
from a service providers as
they're coming and getting
settled and. I will introduce
them su son Kim who is the
executive director for Contra
Costa county family justice
centers.
We have mealy Bacteroidetes.
Division manager of children
and family services.
Services quality assurance
division for Contra Costa
county.
Benicia Johnson.
With C. S. E. C. and that is
commercially sexually exploited
children and you are the
coordinator for cops Costa
county. Isa Mayes interim
executive director for Missy.
If she.
Okay aye Aysha.
Is not come in.
Make it well by the way I did
want to let miss leaves no.
We did invite Ashton.
Chris merger got of.
But that he is busy today.
So could not make it.
And then less.
The guy she.
Board member for pillars of
hope.
Which is a great resource as
well so our four panelists that
we have here today.
Thank you for coming and we will
ask you some will you.
The liberty to kick it off.
Good morning.
.
I took a Tim Grayson has as as
you know really been a leader of
our family justice centers in
contrast the county and. I would
like to thank you for this
opportunity to address any.
Disappoint topic and today I'm
gonna try to use only ten
dollars but not one dollar like
got Tony did but about ten
dollars that's right. Right. So
I'm the executive director of
the family justice center so I
represent the family justice
center here amylose on the
executive committee for the
Contra Costa times alliance to
and.
Human trafficking. And this
coalition has been around for
about.
Ten years you know community.
And I is started first as a
project of the Contra Costa
alliance ten the.
And abuse which was the board of
supervisors initiative that
started in two thousand one to
address domestic violence and
child abuse.
Back in two thousand one we
weren't really thinking about to
identify human trafficking.
But a little later all around
two thousand seven the coalition
started.
With informal activities and
some organizing efforts.
And in two thousand.
Fourteen we've finally hired a
full time coordinator so we were
able to put structure.
And coordination in place.
And so it currently the
coalition consists of about
thirty members of which includes
law enforcement agencies
probation.
.
Community based organizations
such as Comey valid solutions.
And family justice that up and a
lot of organizations working
together.
And we have our various working
committees that address of
raising awareness and expanding
resources for becomes. As well
as.
.
Improving capacity building
follow providers.
And as for as far as the family
justice center IEDs once that's
that a for victims of domestic
violence sexual assault elder
abuse child abuse and human
trafficking. In two thousand
seventeen we assisted three
thousand four hundred families
there was an increase of about
twenty five percent from two
thousand succeed. So the word is
out there.
To any victims of interpersonal
violence that could come to the
family justice advocate and get
the health and healing they
need.
I in terms of human trafficking
becomes aye in Alice center in
two thousand seventeen about two
percent of our clients who are
trafficking victims.
Yes it is a small number
compared to the rest of us
becomes but it is increasing.
And is increasing because
there's more awareness of our
community more identification by
providers and also more
referrals from.
Law enforcement partners
so I think this collaborative
approach of public private
partnership you know county
really has been working very
well.
In addition to providing.
.
Bond services I coordination for
the victim services we provide
capacity the opportunities that
the family justice than a. Real
run a school called the family
justice institute.
So the insecurity is really a
learning opportunity for a lot
of our service providers and
community members so just this
morning we had we are offering
human trafficking one a one. So
most of our providers Dugdale at
the family justice center
learning about him in
trafficking and they are not
here for that reason.
So on the day we opened this
institutes registration on the
first day fifty people
registered so people overly
hungry for that knowledge about
human trafficking in our
community.
So we are offering another
workshop in February. And again
that one is sold out.
So there's just a lot more
interest in the topic and people
are learning about that so I
think that's really good news.
Another thing we do it the
family justice center in call
partnership with the coalition
is to avoid monthly my to this
very team review meeting. And
the key.
We started that in April two
thousand sixteen.
And between two thousand sixteen
are they put it doesn't sixteen
and December two thousand
seventeen we come being.
Fourteen and the team meetings
participated by fifteen to
twenty different partners so
that includes a district
attorney's office. Concord
police which were police
probation on nonprofit providers
and a lot of different different
professionals anywhere between
fifteen to twenty partners
coming together once a month. To
discuss the most complex and
difficult human trafficking
cases.
So if we want to look at this
case is the fourteen case a
fifteen cases that we would
review together.
Or victims were female.
To what goal sex trafficking
cases.
One was at the old labor
trafficking case and twelve
cases involve children drug
trafficking victims.
That kind of goes to show you
how in our community we were
the.
Up prioritize child trafficking
becomes.
If you ask this victims what
their needs are and we asked
them.
I guess can you guess number one
need.
Housing.
The second was education they
wanted to go back to school and
Lauren and we found that there
were barriers with these two
going to get back to school and
a lot.
Third I mental health services.
Fourth legal services
and fifth need was jobs
so this five things basic things
that we or enjoy and our human
trafficking become source
identified as their top needs.
In addition to.
Up providing the services for
human trafficking becomes our
and the team meetings provided
learning opportunities for all
members food at all
professionals became what
capable. Of.
Handling human trafficking
cases.
I want to just briefly talk
about barriers that I want to
spend too much time about it
because that there we are talk
about. The lack of housing the
for sure.
As they can use I think.
We are not quite quite
identifying male victims of UN
traffic
we are not as good at that so we
need more education are on that
and we need more commitment to
the identifying male becomes.
And also labor trafficking I
think we are definitely not.
As good about identify labor
choppy becomes and providing
services to them.
Princess.
The coalition are has produced
the reports I'm gonna leave this
to use him so you could read
them in your spare time.
So the coalition's report also
identifies some of the cases
that we worked on as a coalition
of oda partners. And in a in
Contra Costa county the
coalition members.
Provided services to five
hundred victims between two
thousand fourteen and two
thousand seventeen.
And ninety percent of those
victims will women.
And also labor chucking it was
about ten percent. We believe
that their much labor
trafficking cases out there we
just are not addressing them
adequately someone I give you
this reports.
Up in terms of the additional
resources that we need.
I wanna go back to more
training and resources for labor
trafficking.
And then one of collaboration
across sectors and departments
and different.
Sectors I think up Nancy
o'malley Maienschein.
systems I think that's really
important. I also like the idea
of how to Palos.
A when I was sitting here today
actually I got an email from.
Someone with them mount Diablo
school district
and I was like how timely I too
got this email.
What they're saying is?
Mount double unified school
district has been struggling
with so many young girls and
boys who are being sexually
exploited.
Then or at high risk
the day identified that and they
wanna do something about it in
the school district and they've
reached out to us the family
justice center and the
coalition.
To work together you know we
have this collaboration
opportunities that I would be
point so I went over to talk
about that expanding those
resources to improve
collaboration. Among different
sectors through that we've done
work in silos.
And then I just wanna also
mentioned that.
We need to look up pay
attention to immigrant
communities a marginalized
communities I mean especially
with labor trafficking an
increase language access and
cultural competency normal all
of our partners and agencies who
service becomes.
Well you know that in Contra
Costa county we have about four
hundred fifteen new refugees.
That is each year. There from
Afghanistan so I just learned
this last year. So what are we
doing about these community so
just to pay attention to
marginalized communities.
In terms of your support him.
Everyone is going to be more
money but I'm not going to say
that.
No I would just say that you
know we definitely need to.
Do while I in the area of labor
trafficking.
We need.
More investments inflexible
housing options but becomes and
finally. We need more investment
in prevention education we gotta
go back to elementary school we
gotta start now much school
there's so much that needs to be
done.
Thank you.
That I spent ten dollars you
spend ten dollars. That is
actually thank you so much for
your presentation we will move
right on to our next president
aye presenter.
Neely macaroni.
Thank you I think you chairman
Greenspan and all the panelists
who spoken today so eloquently
about the needs of our human
trafficking victims. I don't
feel like I need to spend that
much time even going over all of
the. Different areas that I
could have potentially done
because the palace have been so
thorough in their comments.
And one of the things I wanted
states it's actually very
inspiring and heart warming to
know that. There's so much
expertise out there because when
you're doing this work it feels
very.
Overwhelming and it feels like.
We're not gonna make any
difference so it felt really
good to me to hear how much.
Expertise is out there and
obviously the expertise leads us
to what more is needed but at
least were were more aware of
what that challenges our.
I'm a division manager with
children and family services in
Contra Costa county. And.
For the last several years I've
been tasked with implementing
the cease act program which is
commercially sexually exploited
children program. In our county
which went into effect in two
thousand fifteen with the
passage of SB eight fifty five.
S. B. fit a fifty five clarified
that.
Children who've been exploited
could be served by the child
welfare system although we had
always been in.
Working with youth who been.
Traffic or had been exploited
it clarified that the children
are actually victims and as such
should be reported to our child
abuse prevention hotline so one
of the things that S. B. eight
fifty five did it clarified that
all.
Suspicion of exploitation and
trafficking whether or not the
parent was aware or did
something to I'm contributed
exploitation it should still be
reported to our hotline and that
we were also tasked with cross
reporting back to law
enforcement. So those were some
of the changes that that
legislature.
A courage my comments today are
going to address the issues
facing our counties human
trafficking coalition pursue son
covered a lot of that. So I'm
gonna focus more specifically on
some of the challenges that face
youth and families who are
served or on coming contact with
the child welfare system.
We do participate from the very
beginning when I got involved
with.
This work I partner with the
human trafficking coalition
because. It's up such complex
work on any. It they require
such capacity in the community
that it made more sense to be
involved with the greater
counties.
Activities so that we could
leverage our resources leverage
our expertise
and be more aware of what is out
there what the gaps are.
Through the legislation as I
mentioned we're tasked with the
requirement to identify. And
track in our child welfare
database.
It's that's a statewide system.
You that have been.
.
Traffic it's either before
coming into foster care after
being in foster care and also
tracking those who are at risk
so a lot of our efforts are
around training our social
workers and our community
partners. Around identification.
We also serve.
Youth and families we provide
case management we provide place
that resources if they come into
foster care. And we also provide
service linkage to our community
partners we don't specifically
provides a mental services but
we work with our kids.
County mental health or
community based organizations to
ensure that families you get.
Link dot and then one of our
primary goals is obviously we
unification R. permanency for
you. Making sure that they're
able to move back home to a safe
home or and to some other
permanent situation.
I'm one of the areas that limits
our ability to serve these.
Victims is actually they use
receptive eighty to services.
As many of us learned through
training that there's aye stages
of change that occur for.
For anyone who's going through
any challenge in their life and
a lot of that you that we had.
Come across are just not even
aware were ready to make a
change and so how that manifests
is that they're often. Be very
difficult to work with.
They're teenagers on there are
resistant to aye acknowledging
that there's a problem they run
away a lot the.
They coming go it's very
challenging and it's very
frustrating for those that want
to help that we all want to go
out and rescue these.
Victims but the reality is they
have to have some willingness to
change or receive the.
Of the assistance and then of
course as a child welfare agency
and also for.
Approach our probation partners
who are charged with making up
placement into foster care
within challenged with them
coming and going out of foster
care.
Taking use with them out back
on to the streets getting
exploited and foster care.
And just that challenge of.
Of care givers whether it's
relatives or foster homes or a
larger facilities.
Group homes having the.
.
The ability and willingness to
deal with layers of trauma.
On the youth that are coming to
us.
It's no it's no accident that
they're being exploited these
are usually I use that have been
abused as young children weather
was severely lacks. Physical
abuse sexual abuse their coming
with layers and layers and
layers of trauma exposure to
violence in their communities
are their homes so it's not.
Easy to take these youth into
your home and for those of you
like myself who have teenagers.
It's just not even easy they're
teenagers they're putting up.
Up beside and I shall a way of
being they want to be.
Adults in some ways so it just
makes it really challenging to
work with them.
At another barrier for child
welfare for probation a
particular who do try to make
placements into the facilities
that we have in California. Is
that.
The regulations that. We.
We are.
Passed with where we're governed
by the state by federal ready
regulation state regulations and
it makes it difficult for us to
navigate a system. And is to
make placements into foster care
our server use when we have to.
Among or working with our
juvenile courts all the youth
have attorneys families have
attorneys.
And it's just makes it
complicated it's not as simple
as just placing a youth in a
home in a. Rural area and just
letting it go it's it's very
calm.
Complicated is really hard to
juggle when you're managing so
many other.
.
Caseload.
Demands other initiatives are
coming down or new changes in
law that our staff have to deal
with.
Some of the resources that we've
identified include like I said
placer resources.
The ability to and the
willingness to serve teenagers
are young.
Young young children.
And how that specialty we there
is training out there now from
on the community colleges who.
Provide curriculum for
caregivers but it's not mandated
it. Mandated that the community
colleges provide that for our
child welfare families but
they're not.
Foster families but they're not
required to go because there's
so many other reasons.
Other training that they need to
do so training on
identification.
And.
Just out like I had said earlier
just being able to emotionally
deal with the layers of trauma
and the fact that you were
opening your home. To potential
violence and.
If especially if exploiters are
still out there. We have and
the.
Youth and foster care are.
Allowed to have a set of
personal rights which were very
important and those personal
rights though sometimes conflict
with our desire to keep them
safe so often they're. Able to
have cell phones we can't take
cellphones away and that's
obviously. As Louise pointed out
social media as a is a huge way
that they're getting.
.
Contacted or exploited or
recruited of what have you so we
we have some challenges I know
there's reform going on in our
system but it's it's it's hard
to balance both.
The other thing that I think
that.
We've identified in this is
been something for a long time
and manage the.
Art hotline for many years and
I'm the the social workers that
manage hotline when I would ask
them what is the biggest thing
that you're seeing. You know
need that you see out there and
it's resources and support for
families with teenagers with
adolescents and I think that
that was even before we identify
that that see sec was occurring
at such a volume. But really
these are families were
struggling with young adults
with their teenagers and there's
nothing in the community toward
them.
You're limited by what health
insurance you have.
And that may or may not be
holistic enough.
So resources around if you're
just someone in the community
you need help parenting your
team.
What's out there in the
community and.
Being able to serve them and
then once they do become clients
of child welfare.
It it is still just as
challenging to find resources to
serve them.
So finally I just want to
encourage the legislature to
trust that the greater societal
issue of child sexual abuse and.
Happy that other isn't mentioned
this.
We really need to get at the
heart of why it's okay for
adults to have sex with children
every that's a societal issue
that's not something that's how
welfare can solve we're
basically. Up receiving kids
who've Bates who. You know have
had years of neglect and abuse
and it cut it starts with some
fundamental issues that.
We're not dealing with in our
society which is why is that
okay.
Why is that okay and so one of
the things I would encourage is
we have partners around the
state who do child abuse
prevention? Education and that's
our child abuse prevention
councils their woefully.
Under under funded.
But there are like our own
child abuse prevention council
is out there doing curriculum
and and school districts they've
been views some of the
trafficking information in
there.
But they're they they need more
resources to expand into
dedicated curriculum for school
districts and I'm sure other on
child abuse prevention councils
with it well.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so very much for your
presentation.
And we will move on to Benicia
Johnson and.
.
Get away.
There was.
Thank you chairman Grayson and
everyone for being here.
I have aye specific role I work
primarily with.
Children who've been sexually
exploited within the county so
I've only been here a few months
so in so many ways I think and
stone the preparation phase. So
hopefully.
I'm able to articulate myself
while as my boss sits next to
me.
Thank you for that.
I think my role has always been
a little bit different I.
I came introduced to sexual
exploited kids when I was twenty
years old. And my first clients
in liberty city Miami Y. has an
eighth grade.
Young man who was selling and
himself at night and he would
show out only on the days that
we had out there. And he would
talk to me about those
experiences so at that time
there were that dilutes the
lingo wasn't even around and the
support wasn't there all the
asked me to do was to just meet
with him and talk about his
feelings and. That was that so
we've come a long way from that
point to actually having
resources and support. And so my
arms testimony I guess today is
really to talk about some of the
services and that. Contra Costa
county is providing and some of
the challenges without but also
our commitment to it and so
it's.
Part of our role is to identify
all children that are at risk or
currently being exploited so
it's not just that you have been
exploiting want to know that if
there's a possibility that you
will be. And we want to
intervene to make sure that we
prevent.
It continuing another part of
that is once we've identified in
were working with you we want to
make sure that we're giving you
the best supports.
Because the problem with the
trauma that they've experienced
is yes you've come in with the
support and you're there with
this is a life long.
Challenge that they will happen
trauma and stays with you and so
I won't necessarily get into
trauma one a one but it's not I
always feel with the visual
sense. It's
most people experience trauma
they once a blink and have it go
away.
Kind of like the rain.
It rains today and tomorrow the
sun comes out and people may
ninety remember that it rainy.
That is not the same far trauma
victims and so one of the things
that's a lot of that Contra
Costa county dies is we're able
to. Get it immediately so we do
have their community violent
solution we do have a twenty
four seven lie crisis line that
people can call. And someone
will go out and meet with this
you.
Some of the barriers with that
is who knows about it.
So that's part of my job is to
make sure that everyone is aware
that leases aware that the other
police officers when they're out
are where everyone needs to know
that that service exists.
The other components is making
sure that people not is a drop
in center.
In Richmond.
I am so we're getting that
information out making sure that
the social workers know that the
laws have changed a lot of it is
the information as things change
we have to get out.
And how we get it out a lot of
times we write things down.
We get brochures we get emails
and I'm since people don't read
it.
But people watch commercials.
People love to see media they
like to see things in front of
them that are flashing in
moving.
And so that's also part of our
strategies that use different
ways of communicating.
Right because a lot of times how
many vets get business cards
wood business cards you
sometimes you look at them any
put away.
And you're like all I remember I
did speak to someone about that
we get no idea where it it. Has
a part of our strategy is also
having our information on a
website.
If you can't get me on the phone
you know exactly where to go to
get that the concept that is
needed.
The other parts as far as
barriers I think I don't need to
get into what more the barriers
are. Aye deftly feel that.
When we're out looking into
giving information.
Sometimes we get the same
And so that becomes a barrier
so if.
Certain people come that only
certain people know.
Everyone needs to know.
Every whether you have children
or not.
Because everyone weekends are
actually each other in different
ways we all catch the part we
all see the five we all go to
the mall well good grocery
stores. Were all interacting
with each other so there's no
need for only one demographic to
go everyone needs sit out and
that's part of our role is to
spread the word.
The great thing about cuts
across the county is working in
a collaborative effort.
We're not alone.
Should never feel like you're
alone in this fight there's so
many resources that you can
connect with and if there's a
resource doesn't exist.
That we can collaborate to
create.
And so that's one thing that's
really great about us working
with the steering committee.
Working with RC sack team to
make sure that we're prepared
making brain awareness week
doing prevention right down to
find our children.
And we're providing the
resources that they need.
I think that's all I need to to
say about.
Working with.
The children and.
Cuts across the county.
Thank you so much for your
energy passion hope.
That you have in your
presentation
S. Johnson and we now will go to
our final presenter.
Today and that is less
Higashi.
But that is pillars of hope.
My can throw away probably
ninety five. Percent of what I
was gonna say because it would
said everything so well.
And thank you so much a assembly
member Grayson for inviting us
here for inviting me here.
As a father as a grandfather in
as a volunteer in despite.
Does something that I'm very
very passionate about. I'm of.
.
I am very encouraged but out but
I'm here today.
I've learned a lot even though
I've I've had no I've gathered a
lot of information in the fight.
One of the things that I do is
I I volunteer for. A.
Home because colors of hope.
There were a very very small
nonprofit.
We struggle everyday to make our
bills we struggle every to give
hope and restoration two girls
that have been.
Better survived human
trafficking.
And one of the things that we do
is we. Give them not only a home
environment but we get them a
loving home environment.
Something that they haven't had
in a very very long time whether
they grew up in a very very
abusive family or whether they
grew up in an abusive situation.
And of course being exploited
that was very very violent
abusive as well.
And.
It's very difficult as eight
organization.
Such as ours to do the things
that we need to do because one
of our barriers is of course is
money. And we've all talked
about money and we work with a
wonderful wonderful NGOs if you
ever. Have a chance to volunteer
for an NGO ninety and I
encourage you in this field. To
volunteer to to
spend a couple days to do.
Whatever you need to do because
you can see a passion gonna see
a calling on the people's lives
to do this fight.
And one of the things is that.
It is to get.
For for media personally is that
I feel that I need to be I need
to get people as passionate
about it as I am.
Against this fight because every
day every minute someone is
being exploited somebody's
daughter is being exploited.
And so as pillars will we like
to do is we like to get that
child we'd like to get the or
what we're up face to right now.
I would like to be a phase one
where we get sea sick kids.
That's a long way down the down
the road.
But right now we're face to we
have a we have adult women
eighteen and over.
And. What we want to do is we
want to give them a holistic?
Care
we want to give them their
dental their medical accounts
lean education. Job training.
And that that I'm quickly costs
money. And it's very very
expensive it's not the it's not
something that we can just do it
a couple dollars we need a lot
of money. So in that in that.
That.
One of our main things we do is
we do a lot fund raising. That
is one of our main focuses
and I feel that that's one of
the things that we know that we
have to do it.
But is something that takes away
time and energy.
Helping these women.
In helping these kids
the other thing we've addresses
well is is you know I I don't
know of any any houses that.
That.
.
That houses voice that had been
exploited across the United
States I think.
I heard of one maybe there's two
now I am not sure.
But that something as a County
at the we need to address as
well.
Is I know that there's I've I've
spoken to people
spoken demand that it had that
been. Exploiters exploited
themselves to survive in the
streets
as a run away running from
adobe's situation.
.
Pillars is is world fairly
young.
Organization
still learning every day every
every. Every person that we come
in we we just start taking
people and.
How women and survivors in the
last year?
So it's been a learning
experience for us and them even
though we.
We fully prepared to to take on
this task everyday it's it it's
new it's a new challenge for us.
So we would love to work with.
Other organizations in
collaboration and down and be
able to.
Make ourselves aware to use
what we provide. To the agencies
and what we can do and what and
and and I don't see what you
guys can do with us.
And to to collaborate so maybe
that some of the costs that we
have. Maybe that can be.
Taken up by another agency as
well.
And I think that if we can
streamline and we come together
as organizations both. A
governmental law enforcement and
NGOs and we can do something
that we're not being so
redundant. In our in our task
for that same person or the
scene.
Same out victim.
Survivor that would be
something that we can do as
well.
The other.
Thing I'd like to speak on is
that and we spoke on and what
can we do better.
And I think one of things we can
do better.
And this something that's also
and very very passion about.
Is that I go to a lot of.
Human trafficking anti human
trafficking things.
And I am.
Sadly to say.
The meetings are with.
Mostly women.
Very few men.
So men.
We are absent in the fight but
we're we're ninety per eight
percent of the demand.
Something wrong with that.
Why don't we their?
When we their in the fight.
We are the demand side.
The reason why these
organizations exist is because
men. By women and children.
That is the only reason why we
are even talking about this.
This something that we need to
address as men.
And and we need to talk or boys
about as well.
Boys these days they say are
exposed to hard core* at the
age of eight.
There's something wrong with
that picture.
I am lucky to also.
Be involved with Alameda
district attorney's office
on.
On.
And he project.
What we address the demand side
but it's a very small fight
right now?
Let's not keep on fighting this
thing downstream let's fight
upstream.
So.
I had I hope I've made myself
clear.
Aye I love.
.
The fact that.
That I get to speak
on this issue.
I love the fact that them I
meeting new people on the
flight.
Idea I thank you for your time.
I thank you for the panels that
spoken I've I've enjoyed every.
And I've learned quite a bit
from you guys so thank you very
much
Mister Gatti thank you for your
strong call and passion in your
presentation. Unless the panel
if you just if you don't mind
staying up here for the last
couple of minutes.
We are going to and I want to
thank the panel as who sent him
for your presentation as well as
miss McElroy miss Johnson and Mr
Akashi.
As provider service providers
we have just a couple more
minutes here and I wanted to
open up the opportunity.
To in this session with public
comment are are there any folks
or anyone here. That would like
to come and make public comment.
Seeing none then.
Or do I.
Okay will come forward there's a
podium right over here.
Public comment NDEs.
About two minutes for each
speaker so if you have a comment
you have about two minutes.
Please.
Yeah I just like to comment
about one thing.
You have all these people that
are being sent up for
trafficking.
He's been in the papers left and
right.
But what I like to know is.
Why in the world are these
people get enough with the
deals?
Every time you turn around.
It's a plea deal.
A plea deal to where.
Okay.
Well his name is senior again.
Why is it taking care of the
first time?
Why isn't just cut?
To where. Hey.
He's gone out.
And he's trafficking these.
Women.
Underage girls.
And he gets a free deal.
He does go to prison.
But he's gonna be out maybe ten
years.
Maybe seven years.
Why is he put away for life?
I don't understand that.
It goes over and over and over.
They had one guy and you're
that.
From Lafayette.
I mean it took you repeat this
corpus to finally find out what
he was up to.
It took over ten years.
I don't understand it.
It's not so much on the streets.
But through the court system.
And that is where we're having
problems.
And if anything else like we've
done our right with marijuana we
may that to where. You can buy
for bags and.
Whatever.
But the thing is is wears is
going to stop.
Why can't we get something out
there to where?
Okay.
You're gonna put for twenty five
years.
Obviously.
It's not happening.
Because these people.
Get back on the streets.
And they do what they did
before.
And it doesn't make any sense to
me.
Thank you.
Thank you very come and if you
don't mind just stating your
name for just for the record.
John doors said Concord
California.
One of our constituents and
assembly district fourteen.
Any other public comments
please.
Simply state your name and.
My name's Kanyon them thank.
.
And I appreciate you holding
this.
Today I think this is a great
opportunity for.
A lot of different organizations
and people like me in the
community to really be able to
partner. And really.
Make a difference.
.
Feet first is an organization
that has over twenty years
experience.
In empowering young adults in
use in.
Overcoming the human
trafficking and.
Trauma that they've endured.
And and there is many.
I know other organizations I've
been part of pillars of hope in
the past and.
I'm really actually anxious to.
Talk with some of the panel
members today individually to
really partner with.
Building stronger programs that
are there and.
Bringing programs into the
school districts and really
reaching out to the youth the
elementary schools so I just
wanted to say thank you. And I
look forward to working with.
Many of you
if you thank you and thank you
for your services well. Other
public comment.
Seeing none then I want to thank
all of.
All of you for your time and
for your testimony I also.
Especially want to thank my
staff
who have worked tirelessly and.
And with all effort and energy
pouring themselves and to making
this happen so thank you to my
staff both from the capitol as
well as from the district. For
all of your hard hard work and.
For being genuine and our party
your passion as well. And that I
would also like to.
Thank all of the panelists
and.
For the other elected in the
room.
De a o'malley thank you so much
for as it was already described
by someone else for being that
tip of the spear. And helping
move this forward to where we
are today. And others now are
picking up the baton and
carrying the weight with you and
so thank you for all of your
efforts.
This is an important issue that
demands reflection and continue
discussion about how our current
laws and services work to assist
victims of human trafficking.
Again I think everyone for the
input and participation that you
provided today and I look
forward to working on solutions
to the issues raised here. And.
That we will continue to see in
challenges that come forward
thank you again very much this
hearing is adjourned